there has been another hacking to death
incident in Bangladesh
by suspected Islamic extremists to catch
you up if you haven't been following
this that last year doctor Abhijit Roy
was hacked to death by assailants with
cleavers last year o Asakura Rahman was
hacked to death by extremists with
cleavers last year secular bloggers
Ananta Bijoy dass was hacked to death by
extremists with cleavers and last year
science and rationalists association of
india organiser neil oi Chatterjee was
decapitated in his home and had his
hands cut off last year 43 year old
faisal arrogant epon was found dead in
his office and earlier this month or
maybe late March I believe was earlier
this month 28 year old Nazimuddin Samad
was hacked to death for purportedly
promoting atheism and now we have
learned that 58 year old university
professor a resolume Siddiqui has been
hacked to death in bangladesh he was
attacked with machetes as he left home
to go to work police say the attack is
very similar to the killings of secular
bloggers and atheists by suspected
Islamic extremists however Louis we do
have a bit of a different situation here
supposed supposed Islamic state
militants say yeah we killed him for
quote calling to atheism and Bangladesh
the problem is this man has not actually
written anything controversial every
indication is that he was not really an
atheist friends say he was not an
atheist others say he was not calling
anyone to atheism so the possibility
here Louis is the political situation in
Bangladesh is out of control right the
current ruling party has been sort of
calling the opposition party among
politicians in Bangladesh religion often
doesn't really mean that much so this
could be more political and they may
have staged this in a way to be
reminiscent of these past targeting's of
secular atheist etc bloggers and writers
and researchers scholars but that
actually this was a politically
motivated killing it's possible and this
does seem to be slightly different than
the ones we've seen I yes it's possible
but these Islamic state militants or
associated militants whatever they
usually don't lie about this type of
thing because they don't really have a
reason to so I believe them when they
say they did when they did this and and
when they accept responsibility for
other attacks and murders I find that
that's generally trustworthy information
yeah although it's possible that they're
not that directly involved in every
individual instance or action that is
taking place and generally it sort of
follows the mo that we've seen and they
have no particular reason to think that
it was anybody other than someone who
has pledged allegiance to them so to
speak I don't know there are differences
and the big differences the friends are
saying that this guy wasn't an atheist
and he wasn't calling to atheism and we
also have to consider they have no
reason to lie that is true at the same
time while there was no written material
promoting atheism or blogs or whatever
anything like that it probably doesn't
take much I mean if you are just having
a conversation or or speaking among
friends or or peers yeah about something
I mean it probably really doesn't take
much to to set some of these people off
whatever the reasons for the killing the
killing is horrific and the problems in
Bangladesh don't don't seem at all like
they're going to be resolved anytime
soon will we ever get the truth about
this story
I don't really know we'll take a break
more after this with economist Richard
wolf Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s